You wake up in the morning, the sun is
shining, the birds are singing. You open
your laptop and click on X to find out
who you're supposed to be enraged at all
day, and then you see
Wait a moment.
It's me.
I'm the one I'm supposed to be enraged
at all day.
Just ask all the world's leading
defenders of child marriage.
David Wood recently admitted to graping
two underage girls and forcibly
sodomizing them. He hid this from his
audience for decades and only revealed
it after others threatened to go public.
This is who Jews picked to spread
Zionism to Christians.
You Christians have the spine to call
our prophet a pedophile when your role
model David Wood grapes little girls?
Also, what is Muhammadanism? It's called
Islam. We don't call your religion
Jesusism, do we?
David Wood is a disgusting pedo. This is
the same guy who has been attacking
Islam for decades, yet he himself is
guilty of what he accuses Islam of.
Wow, we have a pedophile apologist over
here. You really don't care about the
child grape victims at all. David Wood
is running out freely and must face
justice for his child grape crimes, or
do you disagree?
David Wood, bloodthirsty psychopath,
pedophile, grapist, trafficker,
cross-dresser, gender dysphoric, all
public information.
Child grapist David Wood keep calling
Muhammad, who married a woman, a woman,
named Aisha pedo even though Aisha
wasn't a child, wasn't a child?
David Wood, ladies and gentlemen, the
most popular Christian apologist.
Sweet. The predator who fabricated the
Al-Zou story.
I guess I traveled back in time and
inserted the story into your sources,
just like the Zou inserted
I'll save that for another time.
The pedophile who insults our beloved
prophet. He proudly says, "I had sex
with two girls, 13 and 15."
Apparently, these Dawagandists are
trying to assassinate my character.
They're calling me awful names and
saying mean things about me and
besmirching my reputation. Who could
have foreseen this?
Life lesson for you, Dawa guys. Beware
of D Wood when he comes to you bearing
gifts.
In this video, I'm going to respond to
these heinous allegations against me.
Just in case any of you out there are
convinced that 18-year-old D Wood was a
really good guy, I'll share even more
about my past, so maybe you can finally
understand what you're dealing with.
And then we'll see how the tactical
geniuses over at Team Dawa just buried
their fake prophet and their entire
religion, and trust me, it goes way
beyond the obvious. They have absolutely
no clue what they just did by showing us
how to use terms like grape and
pedophile. Again, this goes way beyond
the obvious, the obvious being Muhammad.
But first, what are these guys even
talking about?
Well, in case you missed our 6-hour live
stream, every several years me and Sam
Shamoun go to war. We normally keep it
behind the scenes. This time it spilled
over and he started attacking AP in
public, which would have been fine if I
thought he had any genuine concern for
AP or anyone else involved. AP has made
decisions, sometimes stupid decisions,
sometimes bad decisions, sometimes
decisions that would make a billy goat
puke.
But he's also been a Christian for all
of 5 seconds, so people who are
criticizing him need to be people who
actually care about the well-being of
everyone involved and not people who
hate him for some other reason and are
just looking for an opportunity to
attack him.
Sam hates AP because he thinks I chose
AP over him. I used to do live streams
with Sam, now I do live streams with AP.
So, I've known for the past few years
that Sam was going to go after AP as
soon as he got the chance. Then it
happened and I let Sam know that if he
keeps going after AP in public, I'm
going to hold him to the same standard
and go after him in public.
He responded by threatening to attack
and expose me.
And I was thinking expose me for what?
What could you possibly say about me
that's anywhere close to what I've been
saying about myself for years?
And on what planet am I the guy who's
trying to cover up things I've done?
So, it's a really weird situation. Some
people just have their go-to method of
attacking other people and they'll still
use that method even if it's against
someone the method will never work on.
It's like death threats. If you
criticize Muhammad, keyboard jihadis
will send you death threats, and death
threats work on some people.
They don't work on everyone.
But keyboard jihadis will still send
death threats even when they don't work
at all because they just don't have a
plan B.
So, Sam has his method. If you cross
him, he'll threaten to attack and expose
you.
I've known Sam for more than two decades
and I've learned that the only thing he
respects in response is going completely
nuclear.
If you start going back and forth with
him, it'll go on for months or years. If
you dial it up to a million, he'll flip
out for a bit, then calm down. I think
it's a Middle Eastern thing.
Side note for all of you who are about
to say, "But David, the Dawa guys are
seeing all of this. You guys are helping
Dawa."
Oh my goodness, stop embarrassing
yourselves. Sam and I could beat each
other senseless in the octagon every day
for the next 20 years. It's not going to
help Dawa. Dawa is a joke. It's
collapsing and there's nothing the Dawa
guys can do to stop it. So, I went
nuclear. We talked about AP, then we
talked about Sam, then we went through
Sam's attacks on me and they sucked. But
I wanted Sam to understand that his
tactic is never, ever going to work on
me.
Let me share Wood's words of wisdom
here.
It's almost always a waste of time to
tell a manipulator to stop using a
manipulation tactic or to tell him that
it's wrong to use a manipulation tactic.
By far the best way to get a manipulator
to stop using
a manipulation tactic is to show him
that you know the tactic and that
there's absolutely no scenario where
it's ever going to work on you.
So, to get that point across, I
announced that I would expose myself for
way worse things than Sam could ever
come up with.
Think about why that works. Imagine
you're trying to blackmail someone.
You say, "Hey,
you're going to do what I want or I'm
going to expose you. I have a video of
you speeding. I saw you going 55 in a 54
and I'll tell the whole world if you
don't do what I say."
And the guy you're trying to blackmail
says, "55 in a 54? Dude, I killed 10
people and I sell crack."
You probably realize pretty quickly that
your little 55 in a 54 trick isn't going
to work on this guy.
So,
I wanted to make that clear. I also
wanted people to understand that they
don't need to cover up things they've
done.
You don't need to blab everything to the
entire world like I do, but it's really,
really good for you to have a friend or
a small group of people that you trust
enough to be totally honest with them.
If you don't have something like that,
you run the risk of living a double
life, and living a double life will
crush you spiritually. Way better to be
completely open with at least someone.
Or you can blab your sins to the entire
world like your boy D Wood.
In that live stream, I confessed to
doing horrible things.
The ones everyone focused on were that
when I was 18 years old, out on bond, I
had sex with a 13-year-old girl and a
15-year-old girl.
Hey, I even mentioned I would like give
Dawa guys some information.
Hey.
So, before I went to prison, before
before I went well, before I went to
jail. So, I was in jail and then I get
out. While I was out on bond before I
went back to jail and then went to
prison.
Dawa guys, here's your stuff. Here's
your stuff.
The last two girls I had sex with before
I went to jail. One Dude.
What?
I don't care.
One was 13 and one was 15.
I pointed out that the girls were fully
grown.
One was 13 and one was 15.
So, when Muhammad ejaculates like, "Oh,
you know what? If a girl's 13, but she
got wide hips." That was the case. She
had big boobs and wide hips, but she was
13. I did not care. I would not I I I
just I didn't care back then.
But I said that it was still evil
because even though they were
post-pubescent, those girls were still
way too young.
In the minds of the Dawa guys, if you
ever did anything, you can you can never
condemn it because you did it once and
you can never like take the opposite
side. So,
I had sex with a 13-year-old girl.
Now, she flung herself at me. So, uh uh
I guess I I can defend it. No, I don't
defend it. Shouldn't have done it.
Doesn't matter if a 13-year-old girl
flings herself at you. Doesn't matter if
she has big boobs and wide hips and so
on.
Uh you don't do that sort of thing.
And how did our Muslim friends react?
David Wood recently admitted to graping
two underage girls. Graping? I did
nothing against their will. Those girls
approached me.
But it's statutory rape, right? Why?
Because girls that young can't consent.
So, according to Daniel Hakikachu,
statutory grape can simply be called
grape.
Daniel, I accept your usage of the word
grape. Let's just call it rape.
Let's make it official. From here on,
any adult who has sex with a girl too
young to consent is guilty of rape and
can appropriately be called a rapist.
No, Daniel, you never get to take this
back and it's going to be hilarious to
see you try.
Daniel continues, and forcibly
sodomizing them.
I didn't forcibly do anything. I said
that with minors, they upgrade charges
to factor in the lack of consent. So,
they would have upgraded any charge to
something like forcible.
But, it sounds like Daniel agrees that
because minors can't consent, anything
done to them can be described as
forcible.
Once again, I accept Daniel's usage of
the word. From now on, any adult who has
sex with a girl too young to consent
shall have his actions labeled as
forcible.
You guys see where I'm going with this,
right?
Trust me, you don't. Again, this goes
way beyond the obvious as you'll soon
see.
Daniel continues, he hid this from his
audience for decades. I hid it because I
never mentioned it. And only revealed it
after others threatened to go public.
Liar. How would anyone threaten to go
public when no one knew it happened
until I said it.
I think we can see why Daniel's fellow
Muslims say this about him.
I testify that I haven't met anyone in
the Dawah that is as deceptive as the
pathological liar Hakikachu. Out of all
those that I've refuted in the past
decade, including atheists,
missionaries, and innovators, Hakikachu
is easily in the second place after
Christian Prince. High praise. But, some
people reacted to the live stream
differently.
Unrelated to Sam, but I want to thank
you, David. When you exposed your own
sins and said what you said about them,
that strongly convicted me to do the
same. Just now, I confessed to someone
close to me about sexual sins I've been
hiding for months, and I had no
intention of confessing prior to
watching this. I didn't even entertain
the thought. But, now I have a huge
weight off my shoulders and my sin no
longer hides in the darkness where like
mold it can grow and fester. Thank you
so much, David. Even if the purpose of
exposing yourself was to disarm Sam, it
also served as an inspiration. God bless
you.
Many people did not understand it, but I
respect you for coming clean. David, you
did it for AP, Sam, and for all of us.
The most powerful live stream David Wood
ever made. This will resonate for many
years to come. God bless you all.
Thanks. I've gained so much more respect
for you, David, and it encourages me to
expose and confess. Maybe not to the
internet, but with close relationships.
The David makes himself unblackmailable
stream.
If Sam is crazy, David Wood is 10 times
crazier than he is. And I think he
proved it on that live stream.
David, I also wish that the church was
just more open. This live stream was so
excellent. Although I heard more than I
bargained for, I am so grateful the Lord
brings together the people he does.
Thanks, AP, David, and Jai for reminding
me of the wonder and love I had for the
church in the beginning.
This was a life changer and paradigm
shifter. Thanks again, David and AP.
Now, let me tell you why I don't care
even slightly if people know about any
of the horrible things I've done and why
these Dawah guys are completely,
utterly, totally insane for running
their mouths. As many of you know, I
attacked my father with a ball-peen
hammer early Thanksgiving morning in
1994.
As I explained recently on Pints With
Aquinas, this was the final step in a
bizarre purification ritual.
I eventually attacked my dad with a
hammer. Um I hit him in the head seven
or eight times with a hammer. I thought
he was dead. I left him for dead. Did
you have a reason for for doing that?
Was he mean to you or He had been mean
to There was For that, there was no
reason. It was not Oh, I'm really mad at
you or something like that. It was It It
was uh I mean, I can describe it. It was
Yeah. like uh every time I was following
a rule, even if it was just like
required. Like, if David, here's what
you have to do. I felt like I was
somehow polluted. Like, something had
been added to my
pure awesomeness and you had added
something to me. And so, I had this
inclination to just whatever you're
trying to make me do, like do the
opposite. And it I would get this
feeling of freedom
whenever I do the opposite. So, it's a
rule, you can't do this. You can't break
into a store. You can't do this. You
can't steal that and stuff. And every
time I did, it felt It felt good. Like,
oh, here's here's the real me. But, you
you have to keep
upping the game, right? And so,
eventually it's I'll I'll kill my own
dad, and then that's going to be like
the real me. Then I'm I'm pure. I'm done
with it. What else can I do after that?
And so, I attacked him with a hammer,
left him for dead. Didn't feel anything.
Didn't feel any remorse or any
No. Just excitement, maybe? No, it was
It was I mean, I thought there was going
to be some
awesome feeling of be like the ultimate
freedom and stuff like that. But, it it
was It was just There was just no
feeling. There was no good There was no
good or bad feeling. There was an
absence of feeling. I can't think of an
English word that accurately describes
what a complete lack of feeling is like.
Numb, empty, some sort of void, they
don't quite cut it.
But, if someone were to write a story
about me during that time, it would seem
weird to me to use the personal pronoun
he.
The correct pronoun would be it. There
was an absence of a person where a
person should be.
So, I left my dad for dead, or maybe it
left its dad for dead.
Got in my truck and I drove from
Virginia to West Virginia.
About 70 or 80 or 90 miles from
Morgantown, where I was heading, my
truck broke down. So, I started
hitchhiking.
A guy picked me up and drove me maybe 20
miles to a gas station, but while he was
driving me, I was thinking,
do I just beat the crap out of this guy
and take his car or do I kill him?
You know what saved this dude?
He started giving me signals that he was
reading my mind.
He knew what I just did to my dad, and
he was part of whatever experiment I was
in. Back then,
when I thought you were reading my mind,
that's when you were safest around me,
because if I wanted to kill you, I would
start thinking,
but maybe that's what they're trying to
get me to do.
And then I wouldn't do anything, because
if that's what you're trying to get me
to do for your experiment, I didn't want
to do it.
So, this guy drops me off. I try calling
my family from the gas station. No one
answers. I decide to hitchhike.
No one picks me up for like the next 30
or 40 miles.
I walked from morning to night, and it
was cold, and I wasn't dressed for the
cold. My face swelled up. My calves
turned into knots, but there was
something perfect about it. It seemed
like I was at war with the entire
universe, and the universe was attacking
me with cold trying to break me.
So, I kept walking. I started throwing
rocks at cars when they didn't stop,
hoping that someone would jump out of a
car and do something so I could take his
car.
Turns out, it's hard to hit a car that
just blew by you going 70.
Nighttime, I find a trailer by Cooper's
Rock. I walk into the trailer. No one's
there. But, I call my family. Someone
finally answers, and my uncle comes and
picks me up. The next day, my mom takes
me to Chestnut Ridge Psychiatric
Hospital. In this mental hospital, I
keep going back and forth between
thinking these doctors and staff are
normal and thinking that I'm part of an
experiment and that they're all in on
it.
There was a window in my room, and I
kept thinking that it was digital. It
was really a screen, and the outside
wasn't real.
Keep in mind, I'd been on the other side
of that window when my mom brought me
there. But, it seemed fake. So, I wanted
to break the window with a chair. But,
then I would think, maybe that's what
they're trying to get me to do. And I
wouldn't do it.
One day, this doctor walks into my room
and says,
David, have you ever been watching a
show or listening to a song and thought
that it was speaking directly to you?
Yes, lots of times. But, how did he know
that?
How is that dude not reading my mind?
Anyway, they keep me there until
Virginia puts out an arrest warrant, and
they move me to a jail in West Virginia,
and then to a jail in Virginia. In
Virginia, they bring me to my
arraignment, but the dumb prosecutor
didn't have the paperwork yet, so the
judge let me out on a low bond.
I got out, and I thought, ha, I just
beat them. I'm going to get away with
this.
I was not going to get away with it, but
my delusions shifted from thinking
people were reading my mind to delusions
of invincibility. I thought I would
always outsmart everyone and that no one
could stop me.
I decided to stay out of trouble until
my trial, so I got two full-time jobs
just to keep myself distracted. My plan
was to stay squeaky clean. It did not
last long. I got in fights at both jobs,
but I didn't get in trouble. I hit a guy
with a shovel at work and choked him
until bloody foam came out of his mouth.
We were friends.
He just quit and never came back. I
didn't get in trouble.
The other place I was working was a
department store.
I kept stealing stuff and didn't get
caught even though
it was obvious. I would grab something
to put in my bag and I would turn and
wave whatever I was stealing at the
security camera and stick it in my bag
because by that time I just thought I
can't be caught. I'm invincible.
Somewhere in all of this I went to some
parties with random people I would meet
even though I hated parties. People were
annoying and disgusting. I went there to
watch them act like idiots.
Not sure you're familiar with these
parties in the 1990s, but it would be a
bunch of kids drinking beer and smoking
weed and having sex.
People had been giving me beer and weed
since I was six, but by the 90s I had
concluded that my brain was the greatest
brain ever
and that I shouldn't pollute such
perfection with beer or drugs.
In those days my morality, if you can
call it that, consisted entirely of one,
do I feel like doing this? And two, do I
think I can get away with it?
Whatever you have in your head that
says, "No, don't do that. That would be
wrong."
I was born without it.
There were always girls who would fling
themselves at the bad boy in the room
and I tended to be the bad boy. So, yes,
among other things I had sex with a
post-pubescent 13-year-old who, for some
reason, was at a party and a
post-pubescent 15-year-old.
And if I hadn't gotten locked up
when I did, I would have done way worse
than that.
I mean, I used to sit around fantasizing
about peeling people's skin off.
Once I started fantasizing, it was only
a matter of time.
You know what's weird?
When I remember things from the time I
was out on bonds, 1994-1995,
I see myself from the outside, but I
don't have a face.
And it's not just blank like Mr. Potato
Head without any pieces added. It's like
gray and copper-colored thick liquid,
almost like Jell-O, and it's moving.
Kind of creepy.
Anyway,
the last thing I was about to do before
I went back to jail was burn someone's
house down.
There was some kid, I don't even
remember what he did to tick me off. He
jumped into a fight once when I was
beating the crap out of his friend, but
that didn't really bother me. He did
something else I don't remember, but I
decided to burn his house down.
He still lived with his parents, so I
found out where he lived. I made a
Molotov cocktail. I was going to light
it and throw it at his house in the
middle of the night. Then I thought,
"Well, they might wake up if they hear a
Molotov smashing against their house."
So, I figured I'd
do it more quietly. I bought a 5-gallon
jug of gasoline and I was experimenting
by mixing it with oil to see what burned
best.
I was going to pour it all around his
house and light it up and see who makes
it out alive.
And that's when I went to court and they
found me guilty. It was really, really
good for the world that I went back to
jail when I did.
If you saw my testimony video, you know
what happened. They put me in another
mental hospital because no one brought
up my mental health history until after
the trial. And when they found out after
the trial, they weren't convinced that I
was competent to stand trial.
Went to a mental hospital for a while. I
didn't tell them anything about
delusional thoughts of people reading my
mind or anything like that.
So, all they knew was the antisocial
personality disorder part and they don't
keep psychopaths in mental hospitals,
they keep them in prison.
Went back to the jail and I eventually
ended up in a dorm with a guy who turned
himself in for 21 felonies. My first
role model as a Christian was a guy who
spent years committing crimes, got away
with everything, became a Christian,
joined the Navy,
talked to some counselor about feeling
guilty for the things he had done and he
walked into a police station one day and
started confessing.
No one would have ever caught him. No
one was looking for him.
He just decided to be brutally honest.
That one act of insane honesty cost him
a lot, decades of his life in prison.
But where would I be right now if God
hadn't used that one act of faithfulness
and trust in God to annoy me so much
that I started studying Christianity
just to show this guy what an idiot he
was.
After a few months of arguing with
Randy, they put me in isolation because
I thought I was trying to starve myself
to death, but I kept reading
about a man who had an interesting habit
of taking the most screwed-up people on
the planet and turning them into
something else.
Just so you know that God is the same
yesterday and today and forever, here's
Mark 5.
They went across the lake to the region
of the Gerasenes. When Jesus got out of
the boat, a man with an impure spirit
came from the tombs to meet him.
This man lived in the tombs and no one
could bind him anymore, not even with a
chain. For he had often been chained
hand and foot, but he tore the chains
apart and broke the irons on his feet.
No one was strong enough to subdue him.
Night and day, among the tombs and in
the hills, he would cry out and cut
himself with stones.
When he saw Jesus from a distance, he
ran and fell on his knees in front of
him. He shouted at the top of his voice,
"What do you want with me, Jesus, son of
the Most High God? In God's name, don't
torture me."
For Jesus had said to him, "Come out of
this man, you impure spirit."
Then Jesus asked him, "What is your
name?"
"My name is Legion," he replied, "for we
are many."
And he begged Jesus again and again not
to send them out of the area.
A large herd of pigs was feeding on the
nearby hillside. The demons begged
Jesus, "Send us among the pigs. Allow us
to go into them."
He gave them permission and the impure
spirits came out and went into the pigs.
The herd, about 2,000 in number, rushed
down the steep bank into the lake and
were drowned.
Those tending the pigs ran off and
reported this in the town and
countryside and the people went out to
see what had happened.
When they came to Jesus, they saw the
man who had been possessed by the legion
of demons sitting there, dressed and in
his right mind, and they were afraid.
Those who had seen it told the people
what had happened to the demon-possessed
man and told about the pigs as well.
Then the people began to plead with
Jesus to leave their region.
As Jesus was getting into the boat, the
man who had been demon-possessed begged
to go with him.
Jesus did not let him, but said, "Go
home to your own people and tell them
how much the Lord has done for you and
how he has had mercy on you."
So, the man went away and began to tell
in the Decapolis how much Jesus had done
for him.
And all the people were amazed.
Muslims,
does it amaze you that Jesus, and I mean
the real Jesus, not the cheap knockoff
we read about in that 7th century
collection of Jesus fan fiction you call
the Quran?
Does it amaze you that Jesus can take
the most pathetic piece of garbage on
the planet and send him out as an
unstoppable witness?
Imagine the man who'd had a legion of
demons cast out of him walking into
town.
People start making fun of him. Haha.
This guy used to cut himself with
stones.
This guy used to live in tombs.
This guy was possessed by a bunch of
demons. Now he's here preaching about
Jesus. What a loser.
Do you think any of that would silence
him?
Again,
you can get the rest of my story in my
subway video. I'll link to it, but I
eventually prayed in that isolation
cell. I said, "God, I don't know if I'm
going to believe in you tomorrow,
but I believe in you
right now.
If you can do anything with me, you're
welcome to it."
My Muslim friends,
don't you find it just a little bit
interesting that the guy who prayed that
prayer nearly 30 years ago is out here
wrecking your fake prophet
and just getting warmed up because you
have no clue what's coming?
And you try every trick in your little
playbook and you can't figure out how to
even slow him down because he's
completely immune to everything you've
got?
You can't stop attacking him, but
whenever you attack him, it points
people to the power of the gospel to
transform lives and ends up exposing
your fake prophet even more?
You're telling me you don't find that
just a little bit interesting?
Speaking of exposing your fake prophet,
remember when we decided how we would
use terms like rape and pedophile?
Remember that?
Remember when I told everyone that this
goes way beyond the obvious?
I'll be traveling this week. Got a
couple of conferences.
But when I get back, I'm going to post
the follow-up.
Obviously, we'll be talking about
Muhammad who did something with a
pre-pubescent 9-year-old girl.
What's the word for sex with a young
girl, according to our Dawa friends?
Rape.
And the person who does it is what
according to our Dawa friends?
A pedophile. It's official now.
Only slightly less obvious is that all
the Dawa guys who defend child marriage
can from now on and forevermore be
described as rape apologists and
pedophilia apologists even if they don't
partake themselves.
Much less obvious is something we'll
explore next time.
Have you heard about the virgins our
Muslim friends believe they'll spend
eternity deflowering in paradise?
People who hear about this always say,
"Well, they won't stay virgins for
long."
But, that's not correct. According to
Islam, Allah miraculously rebuilds their
hymens and restores their virginity
every night after they have sex.
So, they're virgins again every morning.
But, here's what's interesting.
The Muslim sources describe these girls
as having budding breasts, breasts that
are just starting to develop.
That's Tanner stage two, two of five.
That's early puberty.
And the girls always stay the same age.
But, we've already seen from our Muslim
friends that sex with a girl who's
young, but has completed puberty, should
still be called rape. And an an adult
who has sex with a girl who's young, but
has completed puberty, should be called
a pedophile.
This means that, according to our Muslim
friends themselves, since they will
spend eternity deflowering Tanner stage
two virgins, they will all be pedophiles
and rapists for all eternity.
And this means that Allah is the god of
infinite rape and pedophilia. The rape
and pedophilia last forever. They're
infinite.
I don't make the rules, guys. I just
enforce them.
Think I can't make this stick, Muslims?
I'll tell you what.
You've got at least a week
to get ready.
You can all unite, any 50 million of
you, and spend all week attacking me and
calling me names.
And you can spend all week preempting my
video. I already told you what I'll be
arguing.
And you can respond to my video as soon
as I post it.
I predict we'll be sitting right here
this time next year with you guys in
full panic mode because everyone will be
saying that, according to your religion,
the religion of eternal rape and
pedophilia, your words, you will all be
rapists and pedophiles forever.
What a way to end the year. And it's
even worse because by the time my video
comes out,
you'll already be scrambling to answer
some tough questions about the Satanic
Verses.
And you're about to learn the hard way
that the responses you heard from your
sheikhs and imams are a complete joke.
What a way to end the worst year in
dawah history.
Little unrelated side note for everyone
else.
You know how I said
that when I remember myself from 1994
and 1995, I don't have a face?
It's just gray and copper-colored moving
jelly.
When I think about things that are
happening in the world today,
everything's covered in that same goop.
What do you think that means?
>> [music]
[music]